c'est au québec qu'on trouve les plus
grandes superficies de bleuets sauvages
en culture en amérique du nord
pourtant les rendements sont bien
inférieurs à ceux d'autres régions
productrices comme le maine où le
nouveau brunswick
des chercheurs et des agriculteurs temps
donc d'élaborer un plan pour optimiser
cette culture
[Musique]
les bleuets ont été cueillis en ce matin
d'octobre on brûle les planches et le
brûlage est une ancienne méthode qui
permettrait aux plans de revenir en
force l'année suivante
le feu aurait aussi le pouvoir de
détruire des maladies fongiques et les
mauvaises herbes
le brûlage est une pratique qui était en
opération il ya plusieurs années qui
avaient été mis ou encore lequel qatar
parce qu'on s'est aperçu que la force
mécanique faisait clairement le travail
à moindre coût
mais avec l'essor de l'agriculture
biologique on voit le brûlage revenir en
force
en plus d'êtres chers la méthode dégage
beaucoup de gaz à effet de serre
pour le chercheur la question se pose le
brûlage en vaut-il le coup est un gain
au niveau de la productivité du blu ray
de pie xii est ce que c'était bien là en
vaut la chandelle à savoir ce que les
coûts sont compensés par le guen rend
demain donc ça c'est loin d'être clair
c'est loin d'être documents démontrent
pas ce qu'on veut faire
le brûlage est une des nombreuses
questions qui intéressent le chercheur
maxime paré à l'université du québec à
chicoutimi dirige une vaste étude sur la
production des bleuets sauvages en
partenariat avec les producteurs de
bleuets
le ministère de l'agriculture du québec
et agriculture et agroalimentaire canada
il tente de mieux comprendre les
pratiques qui ont cours afin de
maximiser les rendements son objectif
offrir plan de cultures adaptées à
chaque ferme temps conventionnel que
biologique
nous sommes au lac saint jean c'est ici
que se trouve la plus grande superficie
et de bleuets sauvages exploité au
canada pourtant le rendement de
production n'est pas optimale
le nombre de kilos de bleuets produit à
l'hectare et nettement inférieur à celui
des provinces de l'atlantique du maire
d autres régions aux autres ils posent
des intérêts sur la bleue à l'année qui
pousse ça là il manque le rendement
reparle de 8,10 pie xii mais les valeurs
des autres citoyens
quand tu es rendu à cinq ou six là tu
t'en vas tu te pète les bretelles c'est
très bon aux mines en nouvelle écosse
comme au nouveau brunswick les engrais
sont épandues chaque année même l'année
de récolte
il faut savoir que les plants de bleuets
donne des fruits
une année sur deux ici en année de
récolte on n'utilise pas d'engrais
on ya vu l'occasion de mettre en marché
un bleuet particulier award du
conventionnel
nous on fait du sans pesticides des faut
pas comparer des pommes avec des tomates
un hasard le chercheur jean laffon
d'agriculture canada est un spécialiste
de la fertilisation dans les bleuetières
avec les rendements soit intéressant de
voir si on est capable de corréler avec
des données de soldes et phd man truck
series d'années seulement
le bleuet sauvage est une plante
indigène est vivace
contrairement aux céréales bio plantes
potagères il est impossible de pratiquer
la rotation de cultures
d'où l'importance de préserver la santé
des sols afin d analyser entre autres y
avoir des observations au microscope
l'apport de mycorhizes de champignons de
micro-organismes tout est analysé des
sols agricoles qu'il faut nourrir faut
prendre soin
il faut mettre les bons produits au bon
temps au bon moment pour vraiment
l'accord répondre aux besoins de la
culture mais c'est pas on veut pas
tomber comme une culture l'extra
commercial avec des gros des grosses
racines dans la graine on veut vraiment
avoir une culture durable puis va se
maintenir au cours des années jean
lafont a démontré que si les grandes
cultures préfère la zot sous forme de
nitrate avec le bleuet c'est le sulfate
d'ammonium qui est approprié
on voit que les résultats de recherches
là qu'on augmente en dix ans et 90% des
rendements dès qu'on applique environ 30
unités d'assaut donc c'est très
intéressant lors à moindre coût le
d'augmenter significativement les rames
à
dans une bleuetière la nappe phréatique
près de la surface au lisima être inséré
sous le système racinaire ou dessus de
l'eau peut fournir d'autres données
puisque en fait tout simplement ici on
le mit à 60 cm de profondeur où on peut
analyser par exemple et en heure en
azote et en phosphore et en rap east
side des contenus dans cette zone
car les chercheurs ont toujours en tête
la même préoccupation une application
optimum des intrants donc on applique
juste le bon produit au bon moment mais
on essaie d'être le plus possible propre
lui-même l'année production et aucun
produit qui mit dans la récolte
[Musique]
les intrants coûte très cher quand vient
le temps de débourser pour en acheter
c'est un pensez-y pierre avec 1 dollar
la livre de bleuets sauvages 2011 a été
la dernière année à un prix intéressant
puis les prix ont baissé 2016 et 2017
ont été payés autour de 35
et depuis 2018 les prix se stabilisent
autour de 57 star calculs faits s'est
investi 55 pour rembourser 48 cents
c'est pas bon mais c'est investi 55 m
c'est beau la météo vient aussi joué un
rôle majeur dans les écarts de rendement
en plus de six colis diminution du
couvert de neige sécheresse des derniers
étés gel à répétition en saison de
croissance
si on regarde sur une échelle de 10 15
les rendements à celle du simple au
double voire le triple donc c'est
difficile à prévoir
c'est dire si la langue qu'on a 10 des
volumes qui varient autant donc essayer
de déstabiliser tout sur le jeu parce
que ça fait partie d'un des dix fils
un autre facteur touche la productivité
à l'hectare les pollinisateurs
jusqu'en 2015 de québec utilisait deux
fois moins de ruches à l'hectare que le
nouveau brunswick sans avoir attrapé la
province voisine la région s'améliore
selon l'agronome du ministère de
l'agriculture du québec qui suit de près
les travaux de recherche
le producteur en plus adopté cette
pratique ne rien mettre un peu plus une
star aussi on a cherché à favoriser ce 4
août avec un programme pour l'inde à la
pollinisation
ces deux dernières années puis ya
beaucoup de producteurs qui se sont
rendus compte qu'un maître des ruches là
c'est un bon savoir jusqu'à doubler la
production pas encore un peu plus mais
quatre tapas et sa belle c'est un peu
comme cet arrêt de toi ça à l'arc avec
un tout petit taureau il va être tout un
manque de chance
depuis deux ans la mortalité dans les
colonies empêcher des apiculteurs de
l'iddri suffisamment d'abeilles on fait
ce qu'on peut avec ce qu'on a
monsieur gobeil rêve d'une butineuses
vaillante sous le temps plus froid de sa
région dans des exemples mais ça va y
avait de laval à laval et se promet la
culotte courte
duras com - hf d'affaires dans moto n'a
fait que l'on vous prenez ces abeilles
lol le soir suite 4 cammas à faire
mourir la piquante qui commence à faire
taire les abeilles en l'impression
d'être rendue en sibérie ça fait quatre
ou six à douze le donne un drôle de choc
quand ils sortent la tête da rocha du
bon vieux seniors je suis rendu et yuma
matin
la tendance mondiale est aux produits
biologiques et comme les engrais ne sont
appliquées qu'une année sur deux pour
certains faire le saut en régie
biologique est tentant un programme de
subvention de québec pourrait citer les
producteurs à faire le changement a été
populaire pour vous donner un exemple en
2018 et 2019 on est allé chercher 42 %
d'augmentation au niveau des superficies
on est rendu à 51 producteurs certifiés
bio
puis il ya encore 35 entreprises après
certification donc c'est pas près de
s'essouffler le mouvement a déjà 16 % de
la superficie totale des bleus
vestiaires et souris j biologique
on dirait que les prix vont favoriser
cette tendance nous on parle de simple
au double entre conventionnelle et
biologique
pour le président du syndicat des
producteurs le prix majoré est
clairement une mesure incitative pour
ses membres
ce sont des enfants blancs allaient
s'atteler on se transforme bio pour voir
les cercles et il y en a qui ont recours
ici à la main de maître en rails
le coût de la main d'oeuvre est un frein
à la culture sont testés side s'est pas
encore les tomates salades et bénévolat
à saclay tout seul pliant à deux volets
d'un côté suivent nous avoir mal en
l'allaitant volta alors je passe par
contre le problème des mauvaises herbes
est moins présent dans les bleus v de
serre bien implanté ce qui fait dire aux
chercheurs que la conversion est
réaliste
si j'avais une boule de cristal
probablement dessine quelques années
l'homme beaucoup beaucoup de superficie
vont être convertis en bien nagé
toutes les pratiques culturales de la
faune show fertilisants les moyens de
lutte ou mauvaises herbes de même qu un
siècle
rien ne sera laissé au hasard par
l'équipe de maxime paris bien déterminé
à offrir aux producteurs le coup de
pouce qui à la fin de l'été pourra faire
la différence
maintenant je pense qu'il faut faire
mieux donc si on augmente un petit peu
plus la production agricole où le
rendement à l'hectare
je pense que le producteur l'industrie
rançon au sens large s'en sortiraient
gagnants
[Musique]